african union leaders met with their
counterparts in brussels for the sixth
au eu summit to reboot and deepen ties
it comes amid tensions about covert
vaccines migration and trade eu
commission president esla fonda lyon
calls it a partnership of equals but is
it really many in africa may disagree
with that as we look at just how
lopsided this partnership is
amid the smiles it's been a complicated
relationship
much is made of europe being africa's
largest trading partner and investor but
africa now has others it can turn to for
better and fairer agreements europe is
concerned about these african
partnerships particularly with china but
some of europe's own policies are
causing harm in africa
for example 54 percent of the
continent's workforce relies on
agriculture but imports from abroad pose
a major threat
staple foods like rice sugar and wheat
from europe retail cheaper here in
nairobi as compared to the local produce
and that's because our farmers are not
as heavily subsidized as their
counterparts in europe and therefore
they cannot compete a kilo of wheat from
europe retails are 20 cheaper than that
which is locally produced
i prefer the one from europe due to its
pricing i cannot buy at 1.58 cents while
the one from europe retails at 90 cents
now the influx of these agricultural
products from europe has led to the
closure of farms and companies leading
to loss of jobs and as a result
high unemployment levels amongst kenyans
with high unemployment many africans
migrate in search of a better life
eighty percent of this movement is
within the continent but some of those
who want to go to europe have taken
dangerous journeys across land and sea
the eu is spending millions of euros to
limit migrant numbers but critics say it
could do more to address the root causes
of this migration which include poor
governance
sahel has seen four successful coups in
the last one year now that's the result
of people's growing frustration over
poor leadership poverty and insecurity
forces led by france have worked
together with regional troops for the
past 10 years to end islamic insurgency
but their efforts so far have been
unproductive and many people in mali for
example are not happy with france they
believe the relationship has mostly been
one-sided economic benefits for the
former coloniser but not much for west
africa
the international community should let
the transition government do its job
we need the international community to
extend its support so that we get out of
this crisis
to get marley out of this mess it's poor
economy and insecurity we need france to
leave this country
european militaries including france and
denmark are now withdrawing soldiers
from west africa
this could signal a reset of the long
relationship with less focus on military
or security aspects
if anything has recently exposed the
true state of affairs between europe and
africa it's been the covert 19 pandemic
as wealthier nations scooped up the
world's vaccine supply africa was
sidelined
to date only 11 percent of people on the
continent are fully vaccinated as if
that was not enough the emergence of new
variants of the coronavirus led many
european countries to swiftly ban travel
from africa except that those measures
were not applied to wealthier nations
where the variants were also found
many south africans were furious about
the measures introduced travel bans and
flight restrictions once again had a
devastating impact on the economy here
and scientists in south africa said
they're basically being punished for the
good work they're doing and some even
openly asked if other countries would
have implemented the same measures if
omicron was detected outside africa
local vaccine production is the latest
bone of contention south africa has been
asking for a intellectual property right
waiver in order to produce mrna vaccines
here on the continent something that
germany in particular has been opposing
one key feature in the relationship
between the two sides has been aid the
eu channels nearly 20 billion euros to
africa every year the system is helping
many african governments stay afloat but
critics say it also keeps the recipients
perpetually dependent on these handouts
so it's clear that both sides need to
review and revamp the terms of their
dealings to be able to achieve that
equal partnership they speak of
the african union chairman maki sal said
their summit was a way to quote achieve
a renewed modernized and more
action-oriented partnership for france's
president emmanuel macron it was a
chance to prove why europe should be
africa's most reliable partner my
colleague christine mundoa followed the
summit and tells us more
so 40 delegations from africa traveled
to the european capital brussels for
this summit and there were high
expectations coming in not all of them
were met but there were some significant
developments chief among them is that
there is going to be the transfer of
mrna technology to six african countries
which will effectively
see the manufacturing of vaccines on the
continent beyond addressing the vaccine
inequity on the continent right now this
is also going to
be developed to combat other diseases
like malaria and eventually cancer down
the line so
this is a significant uh development
although many african heads of state are
still calling for the lifting of those
patents to be able to make vaccines on
their own using their own pharmaceutical
capacities
they was also there was also the big
announcement of uh the european union's
investment
onto the continent under the name of the
global gateway scheme this is basically
europe's answer to china's baltimore
road initiative much of this money is
going to be committed to infrastructure
projects across the continent now this
summit was supposed to take place in
2020 it was pushed back because of the
pandemic and in that time we've really
seen relations between the two
geopolitical neighbors sour to an extent
very emotional language you've heard
about vaccine apartheid among other
things as african leaders felt that
their european counterparts left them
out in the cold in the pandemic so it
was important
that they could meet face to face that
they could discuss certain issues
and make some progress as some delegates
were telling us
as the meetings were going along so they
all head back now to their capital some
have had successful bilateral meetings
where they've struck up even more deals
and this is what makes a summit like
this even more important because it does
boost someone's profile on the domestic
stage but overall
that relationship between europe and
africa on the question that we're asking
is it an equal partnership a partnership
of equals well
we're not quite uhuru just yet right but
i think the fact that you've had such
uptake and interest in the summit uh
willingness to cooperate engage is is a
positive sign and of course time will
tell if things are eventually getting
better in that sense
[Music]
you're watching dw news africa still to
come
how artists from ghana and spain are
reaping the benefits of collaboration
just another example of what an equal
partnership between africa and europe
can be like
that is the aueu partnership a genuine
relationship of equals we'll hear from a
member of the european parliament who
believes that
has never been the case
the european countries have always been
babysitting africa one area where the
balance of power between africa and
europe is one-sided is when it comes to
trade african nations generally struggle
to compete on the international market
in ghana for example the local tomato
industry is under serious threat
increasing imports of tomato products
from abroad are driving many farmers out
of business
benedicta afrifa is a tomato farmer in
the middle of one of ghana's main
production regions
in the past this was like harvesting red
gold
instead farmers like her have fallen on
tough times
we have a lot of problems which makes it
hard to survive in this country
the biggest challenge is imported
tomatoes
after independence ghana introduced
customs duties to make imports more
expensive
that protected local producers like
benedicta
then ghana joined the world trade
organisation and lowered customs duties
to do so
now it's been flooded with cheap foreign
products
so when benedicta heads to market she's
forced to sell at rock bottom prices
i asked for 320 cds they offered 270 and
said others are giving even less at this
price i won't earn anything
almost half of household spending on
vegetables in ghana goes on tomatoes the
middle classes especially like theirs
canned
with the right investment many believe
ghana could meet some of that demand by
itself
i'll be very happy if we have a company
here in ghana that we produce our own
tomatoes we can them instead of people
going to import it
economist cuabeno otu says that free
trade has not just hurt local farmers
it's also opened the door to poorer
quality
so this one is from china
[Music]
only 30 tomato
about 70 percent's touch
we do not have the capacity
to change these things because we have
lost control over our policy the rwanda
abandoned import of second-hand clothing
from the u.s
and u.s kicked them out of the african
growth and opportunities act
so that is how vicious the response can
be if you try to change policy to favor
your own people
free trade should not destroy livelihood
it does make me sad sometimes to the
point of anger because those who profit
are very few
the losers are many
and right now their numbers are growing
as african and european leaders talk
about strengthening economic ties
many on the continent wonder when if
they will ever see the rewards of that
partnership
let's talk more about the relationship
between europe and africa with asita
canco she is a member of the european
parliament and joins us from strasbourg
hello asita now as leaders from europe
and africa gathered for this sixth
edition of the eu eu summit
we were hearing about partnership but is
it a true partnership of equals you
think
of course not it has actually never been
a partnership of equals because
the european countries have always been
babysitting africa
and they have never seen africa as an
adult
area they have never seen african
countries as
diverse
places and so this is very disturbing so
this is what i call a nanny diplomacy
and it's still going on so in my opinion
and it's also based on facts
uh europe is 60 years late in africa and
is currently sleep working it's a real
zombie in africa when we see reality we
are not really believing it and i don't
expect very much
to come out of of this eu africa summit
that has been postponed several times
because this relationship is not being
taken seriously
these are very strong words from you if
you're saying it's not a partnership of
equals
how can it then be a partnership of
equals what can be done to achieve that
i think the first thing that we need to
do is to stop with that aid you know
because this aid is just contributing to
finance corruption
and it's going into the wrong pockets
it's contributing to sustained
dictatorship and we have noticed so many
times that it has not helped improve
anything look at the situation in africa
it's easy we need to count we can count
how much money has been flowing and we
can look at how much improvement has
been made and and then we can see the
hard facts today even
france is running away from mali after
having pumped so much money they did not
succeed to stop islamism there they did
not succeed to uh to build a real
good governance they only succeeded to
help the allied continue to misuse funds
and they have succeeded to open the door
for russian mercenaries so they should
nobody should be proud of how things are
going so i believe this must change
okay so you actually mentioned um france
uh planning to
withdraw its troops from mali
there are a number of security issues in
africa right now especially across the
sahel russia is also trying to tackle
the problem so why does europe have a
problem with that
well i of course
i have a problem with russia because
it's not
it's not russia is not an example of
democracy you need to look at how putin
is treating his opponents
you know with poison and sending them
almost to death
and some even died in prison this is
really actually what we do not want to
keep in africa so if russia has to
pretend to bring democracy in any
african country seriously
anyone who has a little common sense
should never believe in that
so i mean you know if you go to the
dentist and the dentist thief are very
ugly so why would you believe that he
will help you have beautiful teeth it's
it's just
it's just obvious that russia is not an
example of democracy and an example of
security for anyone and you know we
didn't see many africans running away to
migrate to russia did you ever see in
the news that plenty of africans running
away from economic and
and crisis and security crisis and
trying to go to russia so that they can
be safe and healthy and rich no they're
running away to the west they're running
away to europe they don't go to iran
they don't go to saudi arabia they don't
go to russia and that is enough evidence
what is being attacked in in west africa
for example now in the sale malibu
etc
is what we know as western civilization
it is what we know as western values it
is what we are defending as democratic
values and this is under attack not only
by the giadis but also by russia and on
anything related to human rights of
course china doesn't care so what we are
doing is not working we need to make
sure that our companies businesses can
work with the businesses there we need
to make sure that if we actually put
money somewhere that we know where the
money is going that we we know that
we're not complicit of building more
detection more problems this aid is
killing africa
europe wants to be africa's first choice
for economic partnership but china
appears to be the favorite option in
africa is europe willing to offer a
better deal than china
look i think it's
the the point is that the relationship
between eu europe and africa should be
unique
you know it has nothing to do with
whatever china is doing in africa europe
must know
what europe's needs are because in a
partnership or in any relationship even
between two human beings it's about
mutual needs as well so what does europe
want to get out of this relationship why
does europe even need to have a serious
relationship with africa and this is
based on that that the relationship
should be built because we don't need
the same things as china or russia but
we can have a mutual partnership where
it is a win-win situation for both
african countries and european countries
geographically we are also quite close
we speak the same languages as well uh
french english etc so i believe that
this is where we need to start because
europe has an approach and a mindset
that is of the 60s so we need to travel
in time and and come in this in this
century so with this mindset europe is
starting somewhere where everything is
wrong already like we need to help
africa but why don't we start like this
is what we need and africa can actually
be a partner for us to achieve that and
what is in need for them and really
start this way i think that would be a
good way to start and when things are
going wrong stop and say look we are not
doing quite well what we need to stop
here and admit we made a mistake and see
how we can improve things but that's not
what is happening right now
unfortunately and i think that the
europe european countries who continue
to sustain that old-fashioned way of
having relations with africa are
actually guilty of racism this is the
racism that the left is never speaking
about it is a huge international
way of doing that is looking at african
people like people who are less than
other people in the world and i think
this is really heartbreaking
wow it definitely sounds heartbreaking
especially from from how you put it you
elia mentioned the issue of migration
it clearly is still a big problem for
europeans that there are people who
genuinely deserve asylum but it appears
europe is doing more to keep people out
rather than create safe and legal
passages for people to migrate why is
that
look i i'm going to say something here
that maybe people don't know but being a
member of european parliament for more
than two years now working in the libya
committee that is merely dealing with
security migration and fundamental
rights i can tell you that europe is
doing absolutely nothing
about migration policy
europe is talking talking talking but
doing absolutely nothing so what is
happening is that people are still dying
in the sea what is happening is that
europe comes with proposals it was like
in 2020 and until now nothing happened
with these proposals and europe came
back the france came couple of weeks ago
with new ideas so what they do is that
to sleep like during one year and then
come up with new proposals and then come
it's like bringing just the same wine in
a new bottle that is exactly what is
happening but nothing concrete is
happening and that is the problem
because if nothing is happening who is
actually leading the migration policy it
is the human smugglers and you know what
they are doing they are trafficking
women forcing them into prostitution
they are taking money from people
selling
lies and and false hope and having them
go and die in the sea and this is what
is this is what we need to stop by
having an actual migration policy and
what would that migration policy do
first of all stop
the human smugglers by making sure that
it becomes impossible to put people in a
boat to go in the deadly sea that is one
thing second to have a global
partnership with africa that will
develop also economically so that young
people don't need to run away from their
homes to have a security a common
security strategy that actually works
that people are not displaced so it's a
holistic approach that we need to have
and we need to have the humility to
admit that nothing is happening even
commissioned president fondolane
admitted that during her state of the
union speech that we didn't move forward
so i was born and i grew up in africa in
burkina faso what i've seen as a child
and as a teenager is europe come
european leaders coming with checks and
saying on television look we are
bringing this money into africa and
things are going to be resolved we are
watching the news and knowing nothing is
going to change in our lives today i'm a
european leader myself as well and i see
european leaders going to africa and
doing the exact same scenario but what
happens when you keep doing what you
have always done you just get what
you've always gotten
asita canco
thank you very much for your time
[Music]
now what can art teach politics well a
group of urban painters from africa and
europe might have the answer in 2021
they collaborated on a series of
stunning murals in ethiopia
ghanaian artist mohammed awadu paints
pictures of everyday life and ordinary
people and the issues that affect them
so i use those mirrors and graffiti
as a tool to change
perception and educate people about what
is going on things that are not
um
right here in the community education
female
uh teenage pregnancy uh gender issues
and uh
problems of migration
has become one of ghana's most sought
after artists
traveling the globe and collaborating
with other artists
black white me our people one love don't
just go like this bro
this out man
last year he and other artists were
invited to work at the eu's office in
ethiopia's capital addis ababa aoru says
that as much as he enjoyed working
together it also made him realize how
african artists are at a disadvantage
they have all the support they have that
is fund when you want to go to
residency when you want to go to a
festival in another country that there
are institutions that will fund you
fully to go and study and do projects
by in africa trust me or here in ghana
there's no
fun there's no support so but if
we put all these uh
things in place you ask me
we're going to bridge the gap we're
going to
make a better collaboration maria
pennakoto worked with muhammad awaru on
the adisa baba project
she is a multi-disciplinary spanish
artist
whose paintings have won many awards
she says the collaborative work with
african artists has been impactful
see to be there also and to see uh how
great is the
is the art that they are developing it's
very inspiring and also in this case i
would do he's a much more he has much
more experience than me uh so i was
learning a lot from him he and the other
artists were explaining me some
techniques that now i'm using in my work
he works more with spray i work more
with brass so we were sharing
um our experience now
and
it was really
enriching
muhammad awaru's artworks are popular
and can be seen all over accra
with more support he would love to
mentor younger upcoming artists in his
communities
and that's it from our focus on aue
relations bye for now
[Music]
you